When showing avatars,
that is an image representing a person,
it's very common to
show these as a circle.
Now there's no strict
rule about this but
a circle is a friendlier,
more organic way to present the image.
Psychologically, we're also
predisposed to notice faces.
In fact, there's a special part
of our brain dedicated to it.
So using a circular treatment in a UI,
otherwise mostly made up of
rectangles helps them to stand out.
A very simple way to achieve this is to
use the RoundedBitmapDrawable clause.
We use this by
the RoundedBitmapDrawableFactory
which has static methods to create
a rounded image from an existing bitmap,
an input stream, or a file path.
Notice the class is a RoundedBitmap
not a circular bitmap, so
we need to call setCircular
to make it a perfect circle.
If you're using an image
loading library like Glide or
Picasso, as covered in Android
fundamentals two, then take
a look at the image transformation
capabilities they provide.
That's a great way to take care of the
rounding when the image downloads and
on the background.